do you guys remember the tesla roadster
not the classic version
but the new one that elon announced in
the new roadster was supposed to have at
all a 1.9 second zero to 60
a top speed of 250 miles per hour and a
range of 620 miles
coming in at a starting price of two
hundred thousand dollars the first
roadsters were expected to be delivered
in 2020
but clearly that didn't happen and now
it seemed like roadsters won't be
hitting the road till at least 2023 so
what in the world happened to the tesla
roadster
taking a look at the timeline of
roadster delays it's actually
not too exciting the timeline mostly
consists of tesla not giving any updates
and then delaying the car right before
it was supposed to come out the most
recent update we got was in january of
when elon tweeted that engineering would
be finished by the end of 2021
and that production would begin in 2022
given that roadster prototypes
apparently hit all their promise numbers
years ago though what's the big holdup
well
the first big obstacle that they didn't
expect to face when announcing the
roadster
was a near-death experience around the
time the roadster was initially
announced
the model 3 was finally hitting the
market in july of 2017
the first 30 model 3 production vehicles
were delivered and tesla had a small
celebration event
ironically though there wasn't too much
to celebrate
as elon as well as the tesla employees
knew that ramping up production of the
model 3
was going to be a nightmare you see the
first 30 model 3 vehicles were mostly
built by hand
and tesla was yet to employ their
massive automated assembly line
tesla knew that ramping up automated
production was going to be rather
challenging
but they didn't expect it to nearly wipe
them out
when tesla started production issues
would spring up instantly
the robots kept misaligning parts of the
car the software kept crashing
and the worst part was that no one
really knew why
tesla had spent over a billion dollars
building the gigafactory
but it looked like the factory was a
lemon hundreds of quote-unquote
underperforming employees would be fired
and the remaining would be pushed
extremely hard to meet production
numbers
even with this intense pressure though
tesla was nowhere near their 5 000 cars
a week production goal
every week tesla didn't meet their
production numbers they were burning
loads of money
and at one point tesla was within
single-digit weeks of dying the company
would eventually figure it out
and the answer was to simply use less
automation
but reaching production numbers was just
the first of their worries
once the cars were manufactured they
actually had to be delivered
and the problem was that each delivery
was built to order
generally when you buy a car you just go
to the closest dealer
and pick out a car from their lot with
tesla though
everyone custom builds their cars online
there
are only a limited number of options but
given the relatively low volume of
course tesla was building
it was especially hard to come up with
an efficient delivery plan which led
them to losing even more money
considering this massive debacle tesla
experienced it's not hard to see why the
roadster would be the last thing on
their list it should be noted though
that even if tesla didn't experience a
model 3 production nightmare
the roadster would still be lost
priority here's the thing
the roadster targets next german niche
market and it's unlikely that tesla will
crack the six figures
and maybe not even the five figures in
terms of unit sales
so it makes little sense for them to
devote much effort into the roadster
this is especially true when you
consider that tesla still has lots of
room to grow within their fundamental
business
itself just last year they started
production of the model y
and looking forward they won't start
cyber truck production by the end of
this year
and the austin gear factory where the
cyber truck is supposed to be produced
is still under construction itself it's
also likely that tesla would prefer to
avoid a production nightmare when it
comes to the cyber truck
and their new gigafactories evidently
there's plenty of things to focus on
in their primary business itself so the
roadster has never been a priority
and likely won't be one moving forward
either the roadster
is not only a low priority but it also
comes along with a massive price tag in
terms of research
and development just think about it the
roadster is supposed to have a sub 2
second zero to 60
a 620 mile range and it's of course
supposed to be fully electric
developing something like this would no
doubt cost tens if not hundreds of
millions of dollars
for a company like tesla that's really
just breaking even at this point
such an expense is not negligible by any
means
moreover this money could be spent in
other sectors
which would be much more beneficial for
tesla for instance
they could use the money to make the
austin gigafactory bigger and produce
more cars
or they could use the money for
self-driving r d which could accelerate
tesla's vision of creating robo taxis
now money spent on roads to r d isn't a
waste per se
it's common to develop new technology on
flagship experimental vehicles
and then slowly bring down the
technology to lower tiers of vehicles
with the roadster tesla has to develop
more powerful motors
and higher density batteries and these
technologies could definitely be brought
down to the model s and x
and even the model 3 and y eventually
but
though having a model 3 with a range of
1000 miles or something like that
would be insane would tripling the range
of model 3
really triple the sales of a model 3 not
really
so tesla isn't really in any rush to
develop this advanced technology
and break it down to the lower models
but wait a minute
didn't tesla reveal that they already
have working prototypes that can hit all
the specs they outlined
in that case most of the r d is already
completed right
well that only indicates that tesla has
completed tech based r d
not cost based r d not only is tesla
promising specs that destroyed bugattis
but tesla is promising to slash a price
over tenfold
it's very possible that tesla figured
out how to achieve roads to specs years
ago
but the problem is that costs five or
six million dollars to produce
with skill maybe they can bring it down
to one to two million dollars
but that's still far ways off from two
hundred thousand dollars a car
so the engineering challenge holding
back tesla may very well be a cost-based
one
as opposed to a tech based one until now
we've discussed a bunch of financial
and technical challenges in bringing the
roadster to market but
i don't think the main reason has
anything to do with objective obstacles
rather i think the main reason the
roadster has yet to hit the roads
is because it's a marketing tool more
than anything the roadster
isn't built to generate profit or reduce
costs or advanced tesla technology
no the roadster is built for one reason
and
one reason only which is building clout
for tesla
since the original roadster tesla's
focused on growing organic interest by
showcasing how electric cars
could be cool in the early 2000s
electric cars were seen as slow
boring and unreliable tesla created the
original roadster to disprove this
notion
using the profits generated from the
sports car tesla created the luxury
model s
and dex and using the profits generated
by the luxury models
tesla created everyday people models
which are the three and why
but at this point there's no longer a
need to generate hype for electric
vehicles
and especially for teslas tesla is
facing a supply problem
not a demand problem as they have way
more demand than they can handle
tesla didn't exactly expect this sure
they expected the model 3 and why they
saw better than
any previous model but the massive
influx of hype following the
announcement of the cyber truck
throughout 2020
was unprecedented tesla no longer needed
an extreme sports car that showed the
electric cars were cool
most tesla owners didn't actually buy a
tesla because it's electric
anyway they bought a tesla because it
carries a certain social status
and it had a super cool feature which is
of course soft driving
the electric aspect of teslas were
simply a side benefit that made tesla
owners feel better about themselves
more times than not though the electric
aspect of teslas were not what pushed
customers to actually
buy a tesla basically everyone
understands that electric cars
are the future sure there's some
disagreement on when evs will take over
but nearly everyone agrees that it's
inevitable so
at this point tesla's primary marketing
goal is no longer to convince people to
go electric
but rather go tesla and the best way to
accomplish this is to build off their
strengths which is their brand image
and their autonomous features
considering their shift in market
sentiment
the roadster no longer plays a critical
marketing role in convincing customers
to go electric
and buy a tesla so there's no rush in
bringing the roadster to market
when will the roadster actually come out
then well
in the 2020 q2 earnings call elon musk
suggested that the roadster will be
built in the fremont factory
in california the fremont factory is
tesla's primary production plant right
now though
so i don't think tesla will want to
devote fremont's production capacity to
the roadster until their total
production output
is much higher fortunately the upcoming
gigafactories in berlin
and austin are expected to be completed
by the end of 2021
if this is the case they should be able
to ramp up production throughout their
first half of 2022
which would heavily alleviate the
pressure on the fremont factory
and at that point tesla could start
producing a roadster at the fremont
factory
which would mean that the first
deliveries would take place in the
second half of 2022
there's almost always delays though so a
more conservative estimate would be the
first half of 2023
so there's still about two years till we
see roadsters being delivered
but does seem like it's finally going to
happen why do you guys think the
roadster has been pushed back
so much comment that down below also
drop a like if you're excited to see the
roadster finally come out
and of course consider joining on
discord community to suggest to future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one